[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
sir
top of the morning top of the morning
top of the afternoon
the Lord's day what's going on I'm a
little tired a lot going on catch a
flight later to a little bit of a
abbreviating show for us
talk to me hustle yourself
tenant what's going on Gerald Mack
what's up Corey Mosley what's going on I
see you OG pop now
popped up what up Thomas belotti what's
going on live Supremacy was said there's
pretty boy you guys at the house what's
going on
that's my dude we gotta get that in the
rocker blade Point going on pain it's
been a minute you know what I'm saying
Lord Metroid holding it down switch gang
in the building Sith Lord what's up
what's going on
I'ma say it anyway no no yeah yeah so
this could be a fun one I said just the
low ones with my Prejudice everybody
kind of politely things up late you know
what I'm saying yes okay oh you got to
put all right but here's the thing see
you Sith Lord you did that but if you
see what's tagged in the in the top of
the chat did you get the aisle one you
know what I'm saying the exclusive with
the 15 off we running the promotion
so you're supposed to get that one I
hope that's the one you got you know I
was telling people just chill just wait
the reasons finalizing everything the
page is up you go check that out
a little bit and um
oh that's what's up okay okay yeah we'll
talk about that we'll talk about that no
doubt King playing soccer
yeah
you just watch it he was doing the
boxing thing shout out to Deontay Wilder
I believe you fought last night got a
little one round stretch it is what it
is also thank you for the audio check
appreciate you brother you already know
but um
are you playing I said okay okay super
duper man okay I see what you're playing
[Music]
wake some people up and uh yeah it's a
real fun one we got some things to talk
about it's been a last minute audible on
the field attic want to talk about the
um being in a situation so Metro you
might want to stay tuned for that and um
[Music]
we're gonna be back I'm gonna grab up
see where these Lords is at
all I see Adam just pops in right now
together
yeah we'll be back
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
we was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all so Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
Snapple and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all so Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
snapping and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just to Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start it regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my CD but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the yoga fire flame that
they can sourcing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back weed with messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and headers be
swearing ain't real but coming to find
out that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beat and they
want to compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
you're also Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
snapping and making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rains you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
hell look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all for
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and Snapple and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
I'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to get
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't get
with that option you're gonna be single
player like Cyrus you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to an even
though I gotta be Neato I know it's my
destiny work to carnido who cares if he
flies he's still a mosquito you swear he
ain't something but really be Stevo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that joke can't ever still be the
king of the statue sister juvenile I've
been cursed with a curse to be Musical
and if you hate it we'll meet in The
Crucible other than nothing it's cool
and it's beautiful we let you know that
your dreams are pursuable whatever you
want to do then it's doable if you got
work on a Sunday it's suitable cause you
can listen to this and you're cubicle on
the Lord day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
to be the hottest mic of of mics the
mics are the hottest yeah it's in the uh
bottom corner you can see that uh what
you call it that make sure your browsing
history is not up there yeah
for the night.com
live the camera is rolling
[Laughter]
and welcome to the I launch podcast LLC
also live on lordsofgaming.net episode
number 276. it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table of the
Lord's date and today we've got Xbox
versus the CMA round what is it probably
three at this point they go I don't know
this round two they did the second
Inquisitor this is the equity The
Inquisitor all right all right no doubt
Bayonetta 3 voice actress boycott Xbox
Keystone teased and meta plus Microsoft
partnership to discuss so we're gonna
get right into it so let's introduce the
Four Horsemen of gaming those original
gaming Knights of the realm here at the
round table with abbreviative intros
because Cog has to get a flight today
but that goes with the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show how we
doing sir doing pretty good uh you know
we'll talk a little bit about scoring uh
later on because I saw some people
asking about it but yeah go have a good
show no doubt no doubt respect it
respect it and of course coming in hot
uh most technical gaming Lord he grunts
the seller cable who lives with a single
player selfless experience and also
that's ostradamus for clarity of the
lord patreon of the iron bank my man
Lord sovereign
a big Rona set down in the building this
week so I was I told my wife I was
laughing I was like you messed up my
streak babe like you know like I I've
been dipping and dodging big rollers
since the beginning
she got me she got me so yeah I've been
a little bit under the weather to say
the least I don't feel a little bit
better today a little bit like I'm still
a horse and I still you know coughing up
lovely stuff but uh other than that I'm
fine
no no gaming though man like I tried to
really do it and it was not happening I
was like I I don't even have the energy
uh yep no your body said wrestling No
Rest that's it keep your eyes closed I
wish I kept my eyes closed last night
though thank you go go Yankees oh
it just it feels like it's the
postseason of the upstarts
I gotta cut my intro
I didn't know something happened anyway
anyway let's say bottom of the ninth
antixton we're down two to one to the
Guardians let's just say that oh wow
okay Galaxy and then and and apparently
like I said it's the postseason of the
upstarts because uh the Padres just
wiped the Dodgers shout out to them
shout out to the um Phillies though my
guys crazy I was talking Reckless look
at y'all now anyway moving on
and of course yeah the Incredible Hulk
of this aka the access gamer the prophet
of Xbox so I mean King of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement ooh beloved how
we do is located
thank everyone I want to thank everyone
that came out yesterday for combat so
first and foremost well let me get a
moment of silence for my man oh man
that's right man
um
you know bad news uh came out and um
yeah he is no longer with us
um so yeah he's gone
doing this thing now coding
someplace else right now but God bless
the rest in peace after this cold and uh
got to interrupt you but yeah definitely
hit me hard or I know in the community
he's been battling for a while
um obviously yeah you know the law is no
secret you know we we were one of the
first to to introduce him to the
community and um his story was
absolutely beautiful to hear from a
technical standpoint obviously later on
obviously the laws did have some issues
with him but as men were able to at
least talk behind the scenes and resolve
that and um at the end of the day I just
saw some things that bothered me you
know and I get it you know we we don't
necessarily are going to agree on
everything that's one thing we've
established with our opinions and other
people's opinions but when someone loses
their life I think there's a respect
that we have to have as human beings I
don't care what's going on right and I
saw a couple things that really
disappointed me and I would hope these
individuals learn from that because at
the end of the day you know is a life
was lost and regardless of whether you
agree with the views or not you know
plea disrespect a human being you know
in their life and shout out to him and
his family you know yeah are you saying
that you heard you saw stuff yeah yeah I
don't even wanna wow yeah I mean just to
reiterate to all that like honestly guys
I'm gonna tell you this right now like
all of the Twitter all this gaming stuff
YouTube yeah this is fake it's fake bro
this ain't real like at the end of the
day that you know beats happen because
it's work or whatever and like you said
behind the scenes you talk about it like
man get over it at the end of the day
all of it is fake all of it is a show
for the most part right
um
behind the scenes we're all human beings
and that that and that's the only thing
that really truly matters so to it's
disappointing to hear that people just
still following those narratives and
this man is no longer with us so yeah
sorry again I'm sorry as I say that
those people ain't gonna learn you know
they they're kind of they're not
mentally all there either yeah to make
someone well if these guys situations
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll let you go okay
I interrupted oh sorry I said trying to
use someone's death to you know fuel
console or scenario like they're not
mentally there either yeah no doubt
don't last thing can I get about you
because I don't [ __ ] was um also rest in
peace to all the Lord bones mom you know
oh my goodness yeah
long struggle please send some love to
Boom his family also over there double
barrel gaming you know subscribe to the
channel boom has been a tremendous
influence in this fam in the community I
don't know what I would do if I lost my
mom so you know appreciate the love was
that you have and um yeah just send some
love to Boom man he's going it's been a
rough week for the game and goes to show
how am I I am because I had no idea okay
I was just been off the grid completely
wow you were going to do your own
personal things yeah King I apologize
this was your segment game no um it's
fine I didn't excuse me you know about
Boone's mother yeah but on on a lighter
note
um thank everybody for coming out last
night and doing combat talk with King
with me it's fantastic stuff so we had
the opportunity first time in the
history I think of boxing we had three
different cards going on at the same day
never seen it before plus we had a UFC
fight
last night so we had Clarissa shields uh
uh and
uh Hub opponent then we had a bumgarden
admire those are all fantastic uh women
that was fighting early and then in the
day and they put on probably the bestest
play even out of the men but then later
on we had uh Deontay Wilder versus
helanius I know y'all don't know who
Hawaii
and we also have Caleb plant versus
Darrell that was on the undercard of
that that uh somebody got planted yeah
PVC always gives good cards but then we
have Devin Haney versus cambosa so last
night a unique position that I was able
to cover two main cards nice I covered
the main card of the Devin Haney versus
camposis and we saw Devin Haney coming
to his own uh in that fight he gave as
good as he got pause and he gave a
little bit more uh and he uh is the
Undisputed uh lightweight champion of
the world uh and he went over there into
foreign territories and oh defending his
titles against the former Champion which
was a real good treat and also to see
the government of uh let me tell you
something Japan look at Australia and
see how they treat a champion how they
have respect for a champion because what
you did to Floyd was something
disgusting and totally uh reprehensible
no doubt no doubt and then we had
Deontay Wilder versus helenius and yeah
last fight and it was the first round
knockout shout out to I'm calling BS off
the rip I'm holding fraudeness off the
rip I'm calling that's your buddy that
was your friend come over got him a bag
it looked great he looked like the
Undertaker when he stretched out with
his eyeballs rolling around the back of
his head it was a good look I mean if
that was a real shot on God you are the
greatest to ever do it punch you are the
man with the skinny legs you was out
there but I'm going to tell you in my
eyes I haven't seen a lot of jobs in my
life
like it looked like a Bruce Southern job
it was it was huh
like uh well you sell it better WWE
sells it better but yeah I was playing
scoring yes sir we're gonna have my uh
my thoughts on that uh got in some good
games and um in fortnite this week and
you know something yeah yeah Game Pass
well no that's an old one that was me
okay Cat Daddy and uh um don't have us
three on the same team so fat daddy yeah
it is that's uh that is a killer squad
we are real killers but yeah you know
fortnite is what's up and that's that's
the only thing I've been playing no
doubt I just just getting past getting
the game passive and of course we have
the game religion himself the Shinobi
long Cognito spread that relative to the
rubbing IOP not telling what you want to
hear what you need to hear shout out to
Mr Maddie plays at the amazing Jess
Gordon up on defining Duke talking about
what's going on talking about Keystone
CMA UK government has had a lot to say
ultimate which is up all the um patreon
we was talking actually that was on
Colin and Maddie talking about games
video also um happy born day Cobra
Commander Colin Moriarty it was his
birthday this week probably about two
days ago so salute to him Alice and fam
in the building you already know
um shout out to the last word he brought
to start guy Travis uh just talking
about everything was going on in the
community Divinity nerves sandbox
National Coming Out Days a lot of things
going over Bungie right now they've been
in the news far as me not much gaming
actually this week to a little man I
really wanted to play Bobby barely got a
chance to play in OverWatch but I got a
new service shout out to my man Genji
that I had to earn after a match and um
a shout out to uh I'll play a little bit
of Destiny you know I played so much
OverWatch I had all of them damn see
that's what that's I think it seems like
what they're doing is if if you played a
certain amount of OverWatch one you come
in with all of them unlocked and because
the only thing that because I you had to
clearly pay for like the characters yeah
the new characters
but I I had all of the OverWatch
characters already unlocked and what's
funny is I didn't even play with Echo
like the entire time I played OverWatch
but I I have like eight days in
OverWatch one yeah I played that I was
like you know what look the game was is
it felt fantastic to me it still felt
good I'm just happy the server issues
were going finally so I was able to get
in very quickly
um it just seems like a really good team
basically I got to speak to the hardcore
like you and and see how overall they
feel like the vibe I got is still good
when you get into the game it's just a
monetization stuff so that's been pretty
much that but uh so if you want to get
into these super chats
yeah all right let me know grab the
super chats not too many uh excuse The
the Reserve nature of my voice today
we got a heck to the Macho Man five
dollar Super Chat oh hell the Lords I
would say something out of pocket about
somebody but the CMA might try to block
me man I like this be safe out here
and as always stop snitch
crusted the chat for game minomics
remember for two months thank you Lord
Bros appreciate it then we have done old
Taco the only way we can get Nintendo
topics on here is when it's
controversial right shaking my head yeah
that was good feedback they haven't had
anything really and and I mean this in
the best way possible there was not much
to talk about it
they release games they didn't sell well
there's nothing out there's there's no
craziness going on over there we can
celebrate it we got to be real here too
like Nintendo for the most part we know
what kind of nonsense they do we we
never have to like talk about it because
they never inconsistent about it like
that you're not getting refunds they're
never changing that so we're gonna keep
talking about it you know it's like
Nintendo's just like buyer games just
shut up that's literally they say like
yeah hey this is the first time in a
while it's the first time in a while
it's a bully Nintendo and they're doing
anything we should talk about the lead
platform a little bit no no for sure
like I get that but but
you know what I think though I think
everybody brought it because they needed
to get it for some weird reason
but it's sitting in the corner in
everybody's house
I don't want to hear that because when
that other came out everybody was
outside
we all did it together and when the last
time we went back
yeah mine is sitting looking at me like
um
there's a reason you say old stuff
because you guys don't play this dude
yeah we got okay I skipped one on
purpose because I want to I want to
leave that one to something okay that's
what you're doing okay yeah yeah so I
skipped on the person you see if
anything else popped in hold on a second
oh God
let me play with you
oh my God stop is sick don't worry I
have an injection
wow wow
whoa
for 14 months what's good Lords y'all
the goat gaming show King don't watch
dream of the fights last night brother
stop hating on the bomb squad
you know what it is stop playing man
yeah I want to see somebody across the
ring that has no ties to you I don't
want you you fighting your cousin
Auntie's niece's Uncle you know no no
ties to you never been here a dude that
hate you I saw that I saw that that
night his head was bouncing like he
really got hit with something yeah yeah
yeah someone's head face how are you the
sparring partner the chief spawn partner
for years they've been taking the shots
for years
why was it pack them up put them in the
casket
come on man make it make it look good
man all I know is we good
salute to the launch all right Peter
Optimus and condolences to Boom CMAs
issues are based on a phase one look
let's wait for a phase two analysis
it'll be okay phase one sending Jim
phase two sending Jim
the absolute doggy should eat a whole V
that's what's up yeah we're caught up I
think yeah we have that one more that
I'm just gonna wait till we we do that
no doubt no doubt I mean so we could do
that that way I could do the poll yeah
do the poll let me go right back oh no
doubt No Doubt last week's our people
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the recent
statements by head of PlayStation
Studios Herman Holst that Sony live
service games will launch day and date
with PC and console do you think that
single player games will eventually do
the same the winner of the three-way ILP
vote at 56 of the vote was yes Sony
recognized the value of more revenue and
new audience introduced to single player
games at the height of the Zeitgeist
coming in at second place with 27 of the
vote was no Sony values the importance
of single play experiences and does not
require them date and date for their
business model and in last place at
fifty percent of the vote was the messy
Lords I don't care all this mobile cross
play but where is my Vita 2 though shout
out to all the Lords
I think it people need to be scared Less
on if somebody's going to continue to uh
you know support single player games and
more if it's Sony going to see that
games as a service makes more money and
they start less funding those games
shout out to the gaming perspective my
man Nicholas that I beat it to the gay
gang no doubt you already know good to
see you up here brother so uh yeah it's
a nice occasion today yeah beautiful on
a case I feel real hold on let me read
two more Super chats
got THX 1138 two dollar Super Chat steam
deck does what Nintendo
that is true that is true that's true
yeah
but the CMA Buck not bucks
all my ninjas hate to see a man yeah
okay all right and then we're gonna go
back to the Super Chat that I skipped
purposely yes just for this occasion we
have the black Harry Potter
you know we we have jump started this
you know what's funny like they're
they're demanding diversity
black Cognito white yeah yeah
you have a white Cognito you're gonna
have a black yeah it's hilarious
the streets are still patiently waiting
on the iron Lord slash bellari pillow
link
ask and ye shall receive we're proud to
present to you hold on a second I gotta
open this up share my screen yes sir and
while you're doing it I'll put the link
in there too
click on it share is that coming through
true yes it is it is I'm gonna pin this
yeah like I like how clean our logo
looks on me that's a beautiful thing so
shout out to the folks at Valaria Halal
and uh and the whole team over there is
for setting up this page
um it's on baby it is odd so it's I'm
seeing you instead of the picture yeah I
don't see you yeah like so it says that
says you were screen sharing and I see
it that's right on my screen okay maybe
it's my fault so y'all see y'all see the
page y'all just want to make sure
everybody nah all I see is I see it's
all talking stop talking that's crazy I
mean on our screen right here right now
yeah it doesn't cut it's not coming up
on our uh Zoom screen but it says I'm
sharing it yeah you are sharing it but
it's not there hold on let's do it let's
do this give me a second let's see if we
it's down there at the bottom I see it
on the actual podcast yeah I don't know
why it's not being that don't show it up
top okay hold on I got it I got it yeah
yeah switch the [ __ ] let's do that come
on all right well maybe not someone said
rest in peace all uh audio listeners
hold on a second we're gonna put this
away oh yeah right okay keep it there
hey you good all right so the link was
going into the chat
shout out to everybody over there
can't see anything
yeah okay
[Laughter]
this is how y'all think y'all can add
something to Unreal Engine Force
it doesn't work why are we waiting just
a clip just put the pit up in there no
doubt all right so I put the link in the
chat and so did uh
so shout out to everyone over Velar if
you're making this happen
um so we have a special a little
something for the first hundred
pre-orders that go up Cog what is the
pre-order code for the first hundred
pre-orders you get 15 off lower 15. let
me know if y'all see the screen now
because I'm sure yeah we see your um
your screensaver oh great awesome this
is all this is perfection
they got the links in the chat guys
it's not looking good right there
yeah we're seeing some clandestine
streaming stuff going on
let's get out of this
God is Not on my page
to do it
are we back are we back we do it live
folks
they said
Paul was that they're the only fans out
for Destiny lovers there we go see it
yes I see it I see it all right your
debt is hilarious
[Laughter]
bull yeah I see it yeah all right
um take off the Whatchamacallit take off
the wolf from Turner
take out the wolf and turn it yeah you
see um the logo right now like the it's
it's emotive oh I know what it'd be I
got you yeah cool oh okay he's talking
about the overlay yeah yeah there we go
yeah yeah there we go there we go I
gotta do everything everything technical
I gotta do look man
there you go technically speaking all
right so scroll down see the nice page
you know what I'm saying keep scrolling
keep scrolling keep scrolling get into
that preview right yeah you see that
premium price everyone yes yes so like
like Sony we feel
I mean but to be fair we we do have
certain things on Teespring that's
around that price like yeah at that
price but it's around that price but
again let's be clear as far as the um if
you hit that link now you will get it
look at Cog look at it
but now if you I gotta hit the pre-order
Lake now the first 100 oh look at some
that's great that's clean right there no
say the first 100 will get 15 percent of
off on that price
these things these things have quality
man they're quality I mean I'm using
mine right now again you see look at
your project I scroll up for a second I
just want to go back because the thing
about it is and this is all seriously
joking go to the posture go to the
postures underneath yeah so what's your
feet down down sir there you go so what
you'll see is you see how most of us
game and this is real talk you see in
that that left side panel that's how
most of us play We're leaning forward
hunch looking where his elbows are on
his knee and that long term in them long
gaming session that is terrible for your
posture you know what I'm saying and
also again for your elbows and that
content that's the only way to play
games
not like that then you all leading up on
the screen with your eyes but anyway but
as you see scrolling you see in the
second picture the vlari goes underneath
right and that's what you put there for
the support and I'm telling y'all right
now
yeah you you really until you have it
yeah you don't realize you don't realize
how much you need it and that's the key
keep scrolling um at it you can scroll
down down Green great stuffing stocking
stuffers great stocking stuff exactly
when you get a chance watch that video I
wish you were not gonna click it now on
stream you'll see something really put
together by the great folks it would be
crazy if we get copyrighted by our own
stuff
no we good we got the tea and then you
see the Lord's our little testimonials
everybody using it you know what I'm
saying checking it out and again you got
your you're perfectly at your questions
and at the bottom we have the Lords of
gaming.net people actually out there
no doubt but look it would have been
dope this is a premium situation again
fantastic product please go out there
and support first 100 pre-orders will
get the discount as soon as you click
the pre-order link it'll automatically
apply the discount on checkout so go get
that go get that Volari you know what
I'm saying get that premium gaming
experience and take care of your health
it's for gaming support if a better
health yeah y'all and when you get that
man you're gonna have to post some
pictures you know also it was stunting
it's for stunting
God forbid you get on a plane and you in
first class because you know this is not
a second class nah this this is you need
to buy a seat for the pillow
don't try to take this in coach don't
call Coach
thing this is first class this is by
yourself this is the most selfish thing
that you have ever like you you'll start
doing so I want to see people doing
selfish things with the pillow like go
to the movie theaters and take the
pillow you selfish things move people
out of your way go to a restaurant with
you just do selfish things with your
selfish very selfish
with it links in the description it
should be pinned right at the top the
ILP Volari link go get that he said for
azuki said can we use the pillow for
other things yes you can
[Laughter]
go check that out and again appreciate
everybody for waiting and being patient
and got that out but it is live now go
support the Lords if we get some big
pre-orders on this we can do some really
special things so really appreciate
everybody to support No Doubt
cool all right
um we got a couple more Super chats
before we move on so let's do that
we got uh the Lazio Taco two dollar
Super Chat goofy move today IOP body
pillow for the ladies
you know what's funny there's a Super
Chat that said I canceled my pre-order
for golf but I said I thought he was
gonna put like my mind was like
that's what I'm reading now face 23 BK
20 in the chat cancel my pre-order for
Gotham Knights on PS5 I expect all games
to have a 60 FPS option this gen gotta
send this Dev a message 70 for a game
that they canceled the last gen version
and no options is a no-go you know what
the crazy thing about that too is I mean
we're going to talk about it yeah
it's actually not a topic I just don't
understand when it comes to why that
game Run okay look you could blame the
series ass because I guess that is a
scapegoat that the uh some of these devs
are gonna try to lay on but just like
then why is other games have a 60 frame
and a 30 frame on the series s but
there's an X version that has a 60 frame
to me it feels like
they they were taking the heat on
Twitter and they just blamed the first
thing they could think of like because
it's just like even if the S can't do
that currently
why is not their version for the X and
the and the developer said that you know
it can't you can't run on one without
the other because Xbox won't let you
yeah but plenty of developers have made
has a 60 frame mode I don't understand
why this one doesn't have a 60 frames
listen if if the if you're as untethered
as they claim to be where the co-op
gameplay is like one character can
approach a scenario completely
differently from the other character and
still be in the same scenario that's
impressive technically right now if that
is the case and that is the reason why
you can't hit that okay I get that I
don't understand I don't understand it
because I'm not going to pretend I
understand the the the science behind it
or you know the technicalities of it but
they're going to be plenty of people
still playing this game single player
why is that not an option for the single
player I don't understand see you
condition players who've now moved over
to the PS5 Xbox series consoles to want
60 FPS and all of a sudden you say nah
we can't after you cancel the last 10
versions in order to focus on these
versions so again looking at the game at
least thus far we don't have the game in
our hands yet right we're looking at the
game it doesn't look graphically special
or above and beyond anything that we've
seen before that would indicate that you
can't do it so again I'm not going to
sit here and act like I know technically
what what they can or can't do but it
just feels it it honestly feels like a
time constraint thing this game has to
come out in October you know this month
whatever and this is a concession that
we've made you know that's what it feels
like this game already had an uphill
battle and they just pretty much like
cut the top part like they said like
this game is gonna flop like hardcore
because I don't know anyone that's
talking positive about this game I don't
and now you're telling people that have
the you know Cartagena they're not still
on the past gen first off you told them
they couldn't even have the game right
so you told the Xbox One PS4 people you
couldn't have the game and then on top
of it they turned around and said not
only can you guys not have the game but
you guys got to play your game like
you're playing on their game system I
think the main issue for me is just to
not disclosure of that technical
information usually you get that
information earlier so that's the part
that's gonna look a little suspect
because people are gonna be like yo how
is it that we're just doing about this
that some people
um I don't want to put the person's
business that told me but some people
was thought this was a four-player game
off the rip and then they'll come to
find out it's a two-player game and then
they're gonna have a four player mode of
a specific thing later coming later it's
so yeah they've in my opinion you know
they have to do a better job of
transparency that's why they're going to
get the smoke I mean that's just it's
selective marketing that's all it is
selective marketing you want to word
your uh your phrases in a way that is
deceiving and it's just like look like
you know you being that extra I'm sorry
but at that point
why do it now a week out from release
yeah because people are probably locked
in already I know what you're saying
anyway
um because I thought it was going to go
to game pass I was holding out yeah and
I didn't you know it's really whatever
the 30 frames per second is really
whatever and they're going to come out
with a patch later on
um oh you know that's happening for sure
yeah yeah with the four player joint but
I ain't buying it even when that patch
comes before I believe it was dying
light and somebody was like oh it can't
be done on a series this is the reason I
mean we got to be careful with whatever
I just want to uh salute to the chat
real quick because people are actually
picking up this Ferrari and asking a lot
of questions so shout out to thank you
yeah so shout out to y'all shout out to
my man um Mitch um he was talking about
the UK and EU shout out to the valari
game fellow shots valari actually
innocent with chat saying that it will
become available to the EU in the UK
early 2023 some people saying that they
um picked up the the valari fellow The
Links at the top no doubt and uh yeah
how you'll know if it you have it it'll
as soon as you click the uh the the
order the checkout you'll see the 15
then applied so you should see it if you
if you ordered it now hopefully you're
within that first one I bought all
hundreds
let's go let's go for you guys man I
bought all the people attic is that dude
with the with the ski mask on and yeah
I don't got PlayStation five I got
Volaris
but yeah it's a weird situation with God
to man I don't know anyway good to
yourself
all right hold on a second so we've got
that
yeah we got that Tony Bryant remember
for 27 months Lord gold thank you sir
happy Lords happy Lord's happy to be
here live pillow is fire not gonna lie
let me play with my joystick gonna order
five of them joints of Salisbury South
Springs cologne under wow
I have a seance
sorry I mean we could you know at some
point maybe offer some you know
autographed autographed uh pillows can
you hear this I'll do a special as you
see me I'm seeing like I am not opening
that that you know there there's quite a
bit yeah that uh if we I try to sign
that many people
[Laughter]
just like King side in the mall
what we do is we have uh three pillows
each person and each person sends a nice
little you know
with a signature and yeah
oh no this is not pepperoni Sunday
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
for 12 months Lord gold here's to
another great show Lords and thanks for
the pillow
much love brother much love get that
velocity gaming right then we got flame
remember for a year five dollar Super
Chat howdy buckaroos please check your
candy this year yeah please check your
candy every year
crazies out there I found Gotham Knights
running at 30 FPS on the next gen
systems in my Twix
wow
uh then we got uh
what they want
a more natural situation that's what we
want
there we have it you got around you
gotta help us move the product yeah I
hope this Pro this podcast Move Along
back two dollars oh hell the IOP salute
the Lord's thank you brother appreciate
it
that we have Mr Irishman five pound
Super Chat uh Hideki caught me his
Twitter account finally collapsed under
the weight of the Blacklist wow yeah
that was um
oh yeah one thing we got to let you guys
know it's this is a pre-order page yes
you won't be getting the pillows to
early 2023 yeah yes yes I don't want
people to be coming at us like where's
the building it's the pre-order page
Christmas yes King said stocking stuff
Christmas is whenever you make it yeah
all of these have to be made as the
pre-orders come in and it's it's a whole
shipping thing so
we have to have plenty of time to get
the king pillows yeah right make sure he
is still on there
attic open door stoppers
move it up
don't come for me unless I send for you
move it off there's gonna be plenty of
people
nice there we go then we got Matt
without field member for 10 months if we
get a King David body pillow would that
make him the comeback King whoa
yeah I like this I like that so all
these innuendos can't be pointed at me
all the time yeah it's just you it's
just you yo they said the Ferrari on
Daddy collection I'm done yeah listen
we'll play with my joystick when you
need it
you need to hurry up a Super Chat
imagine if it's like one of those things
where you could squeeze
where's R Kelly we need R Kelly
yo yo Cog imagine if it's like one of
those pillows you could squeeze it to
say something in King's voice
said man that already missed the
discount oh wait did you order it prior
to the link going up if you did I
couldn't if you could have because if
you just ordered a try to pre-order over
Laurie without before we did the
promotion then he's not gonna have a
discount but if he did it just now it's
automatically included as soon as you
hit wait that's what I'm saying he
couldn't have he could have gotten it
over Larry before not enough
correct correct right so if you if you
went now to get an iron Lords Villari
and there's no more discount that means
we already have 100 pre-orders yo
somebody said the iron Lord King Joy if
you squeeze it and say oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so the discount is Lord 15 just so y'all
know continue another 15. yes
um so yeah I was Curt to the Super Chat
man that I really missed the discount
ordered I I mean if if you if there's no
more discount on that pre-order that
means we got the 100 already right which
is amazing and I'm sorry shout out to
Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive for ordering 99. they got the
daddy died straight yeah we have paid
forever two dollars Super Chat no Alex
no Alex oh yeah Alex was going to be a
permanent member of the podcast
yes so we need to hit the pre-order
targets
that's what Cog meant when he said a new
new in special things coming after that
sheets
listening to all of this and taking down
listen man the people what would they
want we hit this target that's the next
turn that's the next one we're doing
no I'm not doing nothing
for the smoke Don't You Buck up on me
[Laughter]
let's get into it man uh CMA versus Xbox
round two fight still going on I'm just
gonna summarize briefly because it is so
much in this is so yeah the CMA is
unsued shout out to gamesindustry.biz
they unsuade by Microsoft's Arguments
for Activision Blizzard actors position
they issue statements from the UK
regulator dismisses some of Xbox makers
points regarding Call of Duty's
exclusiveness
um I mean yeah in exclusivity so pretty
much they said um they released an uh
issue of statements about their concerns
about the proposed Microsoft active
acquisition of Activision Blizzard and
dismissing several of Xbox's key
arguments they basically started off by
saying Financial modeling of the mergers
suggests that the merge entities
incentive to foreclose Sony may be
considerably stronger than suggested by
the parties Microsoft's past business
practices suggest that it may be willing
to make losses in the short term in
order to build scale and increase its
user base it's continued knowing that
Microsoft has previously acquired
multi-platform Publishers and made their
games exclusives it also dismissed
arguments that Microsoft would keep Call
of Duty multi-platform simply to avoid
publicly backlash saying that it did not
identify any persuasive evidence that
Microsoft would be deterred from
engaging in total or partial foreclosure
strategies by the prospect of
reputational damage to Xbox and Call of
Duty and then they talked about how
obviously Call of Duty can influence
consumer decisions or what to buy and
they finished off by pretty much saying
that um
Sony's uh well exactly impact the
acquisition might have on competition
they said Sony's clear status as
Microsoft's closest rival in a highly
concentrated console Market deserves
specific considerations
how while it acknowledged Nintendo's
role in the market it noted the
companies offered differentiated
Hardware with a more friend friend
family friendly software so they are
distinct that Nintendo is something
different just to be clear you know
saying so they said parties happen to
October 28th to respond and then they uh
there's some more statements there I'm
not going to read anything very long
there's a lot to this and uh most people
here Jim Ryan made this he wrote this
word show me this don't sound like
something generous it sounds like
something it sounds like Jim Ryan like
wrote down specific notes for the CMA
outlining everything that they didn't
understand and and breaking it down to
make it safer
like it's what it feels like because
they're talking about things in a level
of detail that only people that
understand gaming would even think about
thinking in this way like when you when
you start and you differentiate Nintendo
that's not something that any anyone on
the CMA knows off the top of their head
this is something or that they research
right this is something that was handed
to me like hey this is how this Market
is and this is how Nintendo is different
from ours and this is why it doesn't the
argument that they're in second place
and they're surviving What I Call of
Duty doesn't hold water right it doesn't
feel like this is research they would
figure out on their own this is this is
like equivalent to like wanting to take
your ball and go home but you can't go
home because you ain't made money yet
like
they have no other choice but to like
double down like it's crazy yeah it just
really the Inside Job feeling that I get
from the the CMA stuff and anything
going on in Europe is hilarious to me
kind of like because these arguments
they're dismissing the vast majority of
the arguments that were made on the
Brazil side right and acting like their
concerns are completely different from
the rest of the world and uh I overall
I'm so I'm done with this conversation
let me get this right go ahead
the CMA is for the consumer paying ten
dollars more the CMA is for Sony
blackballing uh Xbox when it goes to the
table and it gives these underhanded
contracts to these developers to keep
the stuff off the Xbox platform CMA is
down for everything that Jim does in
raising prices of consoles that already
exist in the market that affect the
consumer I thought the CMA is supposed
to be looking out for the consumer now
looking out for PlayStation so at the
end of the day any idiot that's out here
Champion these fools putting up this
fake brick wall and this is this is
really what where's Jim made his bones
at Jim has made his bones in Europe this
is his backyard that's why it feels
suspect yeah this is this is Hometown
cooking this this is literally the
definition of a favor for a favor yeah
he undid some stuff he didn't cut off
Japan so I'm pretty sure Japan is
definitely going to be in line with sale
right I'm pretty sure that you know
everybody else is going to be online but
this is the one specific reason
that's going to say these things and
these things protect doesn't protect the
consumer because if you take all the
information given to you from what
Sony's business practices have been the
last 25 years which has been detrimental
to the customer at every level from it
streaming to its game packaging to its
boxing
everything have you brought a
PlayStation 5 lately have you seen how
poorly uh a package this thing is all
right so again there's nothing premium
about this situation there's lies from
lies on top of Lies given to you and
there with this why why are they with
this because Jim made that region a
priority and in that region he has gone
a ton of money for this uh this region
right
this is where you see
the dirty business practices of politics
right here and it's it's okay because
one monkey don't stop the show right so
a lot of people feel like this is going
to be the hill that Microsoft dies on no
it's just gonna be you right now you're
going to watch this and you're going to
say damn I really thought they had them
and
when when they start giving out detailed
information
and real dirt starts to fly when you
start to see the real stuff see because
everybody we always assume what what the
what's the deal with the contract with
Final Fantasy right we always assume the
point when it really comes out you're
gonna see how Sinister it really is and
what these dudes is really doing in the
background and I don't absolve Microsoft
from doing whatever they got to do to
survive right but also in them they said
that
they are afraid that Microsoft would be
able to take huge losses in the
beginning right that's to gain ground so
what you're acknowledging is you're
acknowledging the financial backing this
parent company has and they're willing
to take losses in order to erode your
um High standing in the market right so
your market share let's say you're 80
market share they know that Microsoft is
willing to lose tons of money just to
erode your 80 to get it to something
more palatable as a 50 but I don't see
Microsoft as your direct competitor the
closest dudes closest to you is either
um 10 cent or um Embrace a group right
those are the two that is closest to you
and the reason why 10 cent is more of a
competitor to you because they are
issuing a console that is coming to
Market which is the cloud they are part
of that before they weren't they were
just uh uh producers and had development
houses and they had money here and there
now they have an actual machine that can
go up against your machine so they have
formulated a direct attack against Sony
you're not looking at them and you
exclude Nintendo on purpose because
their product is not in the same
architecture as your uh Xbox
architecture right Sony and Microsoft's
locking checks is pretty much the same
right
um and then like what is x80 x82 x86
right uh so I guess they wanted to use
those schematics and say that and
Nintendo's something totally different
right no Nintendo's the market leader
right and they're doing it without Call
of Duty you can do it without Call of
Duty 2. yeah right
and I just don't want to do it argument
no they don't want to do it they want to
continue to use this crutch and they
don't need it but Microsoft isn't taking
it from you right I think it's what
y'all said uh let's add it I'm sorry did
you get your balls off I'm sorry yeah
I'm just not it's just so it's it's
disheartening to see I don't like the
fact that
a lot of these people are championing
talking about oh they're standing up to
Microsoft
so then you like paying ten dollars more
you like you know these companies doing
the stuff that they doing just say that
you like being dominated
oh my God what yeah what it is is again
you said it beautifully which is their
their job is supposed to protect the
consumer right their job is supposed to
make it an even playing field for
Consumer not for a particular company
right shout out to the great chess court
and he actually says something he had a
statement like a couple days back and he
said I can't help but feel like at the
root of It ultimately with sodia against
the CMA is arguing for is to keep things
worse keep Bobby contact in the elt
keep all Studios working on Call of Duty
forever keep Starcraft dead shout out to
every little big pleasure fan Call of
Duty off switch and keep Call of Duty
off Game Pass which would be better for
consumers Jess so Sony can keep the Call
of Duty marketing like is that what the
root of this is so look I'm not
surprised I've told y'all I was like I
had a feeling I Gotta Give me my flower
I said when Jim went over there and we
were all clowning them because they were
getting Tomatoes thrown at them in the
public eye like you really doing all
this when you know Sony went based on
your past exclusive business practices
and keeping things exclusive why would
you go be so Brazen to talk about it in
a way that is clearly you know
beneficial to Consumers where I say the
deal is inadequate seeing that we you
know it's not good for gamers that was
the term right remember he got dragged
which is like which Gamers this is what
I was concerned about because I I felt
in my heart like again without any
specific evidence
that his influence in that region and
how PlayStation has dominated in that
region and he's he has been elevated
because of that absoli brass that you
couldn't tell me he didn't have
influence and I agree with Saul I am not
implying corruption but I find quite
interesting that the statement of the
CMA who is their best interest to
protect the people
seem to read like his statements
verbatim
that is very interesting to me you know
what I'm saying so we got we got to see
how this thing's gonna play out I I I I
honestly think that
for Microsoft to come out in front say
what they said the seat to the seat to
respond to this CMA was big then the CMA
to respond to them is going to be big
but I agree Shadow hockey should you
said this is phase one of the process
honestly my gut is still this is about
concessions this is about even if there
is
Foul Play this is about
what can we get from this situation that
either Microsoft is going to have to
concede from uh Call of Duty you know
being you know not non-exclusive in
perpetuity or Playstation which I think
Microsoft would have no problem
conceding right yeah I'm sure I get that
use my sister you know what I want at
this point man I want I want Microsoft
to call late Bluff like I want Microsoft
to pull out there and be like all right
you know you saying that uh let's say
that they start pushing a little bit
towards not like approving it in in the
UK so we won't sell in the UK won't you
tell your consumers why we won't sell in
the UK and see it and see if they hide
behind that word then like yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be interesting I
know they're not going to call their
Bluff but it is I would want them to
call them it will be interesting to see
how this next phase goes because the
vibe I get is Microsoft's willing to
take it there if it goes to court and
like King is saying if it goes to court
then everybody's dirt comes out and
there's going to be some people you know
that not gonna want their dirt out so
it's in their best interest to resolve
right we're gonna see this this is gonna
enter it's like each each week it's a
new it's a new chapter in this situation
man but yeah this was very very
interesting my only problem is as gamers
you supposed to be championing what's
going to save you money
I'm tired of this fake trend on yeah I'm
happy I'm cool with paying ten dollars
more
I'm happy with them raising the price
over here it's okay for you to love
something but to be outraged at the bad
business practices of said company talk
about it if you go to the store and you
go to go get I see because just recently
we went to go get some soups from BJ's
right these soups was 9.99 before so me
and my wife go pick up the soups and
it's up to 16 yeah I said what the hell
type of inflation is this and it was
just like basically overnight so what
happened was the soup stayed where they
were I can like the soups I can like the
company but I don't have to like the
business practices and I can learn how
to separate the two yeah you guys
sitting there yeah the CMA is standing
up for what's right
norina and you're not standing up for
what's right don't go with the flow into
the slaughterhouse just because you see
all your friends going in there
it don't look right you're seeing people
dying don't it don't look right just
stand up and put your hand up it's okay
you don't have to be down with green but
you could be standing for yourself that
ten dollars if you think about it
five games that's 50 bucks right just
the ten dollars adds up just think about
it the next time you short ten dollars
on something where that ten dollars
could have been and it could have been
in your pocket yeah and the last thing
I'll say is that um you know I'm of the
mindset that I don't feel you someone
should be penalized for the way they
invest or move around their company
because let's be clear you know I know
the only I think the CMA strongest
argument will be the linking of Game
Pass to Azure and how Microsoft has a
strong you know that seems like the
latest thing that they fight over right
and it seems like the prime things that
they keep focusing on over and over
again during this Activision deal is we
can't compete without Call of Duty right
right but what the hell does that have
to do with the ABK deal right well it's
it's a it's a big we can't not
acknowledge that Call of Duty is a huge
game we can't acknowledge not
acknowledge yeah but I mean what does my
cloud what what what does my Ferrari got
to do with my house I'm going to get to
you this is my feeling this is my
feeling right I feel what you say
because they try it seems like they try
to which I think is probably their
strongest argument even more than the
Call of Duty stuff at all stuff but the
issue I have is that Microsoft took the
had the foresight and and the investment
to say we are willing to take a
short-term loss and build this thing
slowly organically with the Azure Cloud
background but let's be clear they
weren't first in the space people forget
sodi was yeah Sony was first with guy
remember guy Kai playing yes now they
were first they invested in space they
did not succeed in the space to the
point where that PS down let's be honest
collectively was a failure which did
force them to merge their actual good
subscription service right PS plus and
bake now into it to try to add value to
it but what I'm trying to say is you
can't in my opinion
penalize someone for investing in
something and having the foresight and
now it is successful say whoa we got to
make it competitive because technically
no one was championing for anyone else
which guy existed I had guy I had PS now
they were first in the space so that to
me is always sucked and the technology
was not good right let's keep it above
no it sucks right
I have a PS3 yeah but I was like let me
let me try this oh my gigabit connection
it was like nah it's a nah you can't
really good you're good we're good yeah
so they're not even using the Microsoft
infrastructure yet hey they're not
really using Azure yet you know shout
out to the post up Sony brought guy Kai
and online yeah they were first like
that's my thing so it's like like King
said it best who CMA who are we serving
here this is just this is really your
job their job is to protect the people
right if you're given to people that
don't let's just look at the Call of
Duty since everyone's so focused on Call
of Duty and you're telling the person
that's a consumer
keep things the way they are now right
the way somebody can have it or if
you're a consumer you know if you have a
switch or you have Game Pass you have
all these options to get it one being
pretty much the fifty dollars a month
and the other on a platform that you
didn't really have it on and the other
Azure potentially on PC or a mobile
device which scenario is better for you
option wise as a consumer it's obvious
it's the second one so who are we
serving here and that's the thing but
honestly I think this is still posturing
it's strong posture you know what I'm
saying but we will see I'll see I want
to see the paper trail yeah
I will say on both sides the dirt will
come out now the vibe I get is
Microsoft's willing to go there and I
don't know if Sony's willing to go there
only because then think about this
addict said it best we didn't know about
the cro remember the fortnite situation
unveiled a lot with the Epic and it
unveiled that Sony actually demands them
to get paid for the privilege of having
cross play for PlayStation involved and
these are the deals and things that the
money we're gonna see come out so who's
willing to Blink on this in my opinion
it's best for both to resolve this
because it could get dirty and I know
who money long and I know who lawyers is
is crazy that's all I'm gonna say and
I'm gonna leave it at that okay can I
address something real quickly people
bringing up that I guess some people are
coming from Tick Tock there's a reason
there's no sound on Tick Tock
because you want you in the chat shout
out to Lord Tick Tock you want to hear
get over here
appreciate y'all no doubt but that's all
I got on it because I know we got a
little breathing show anything else with
y'all y'all good sorry I'm sorry let me
talk something real quick man it's not
related to that okay I just want to say
the Halloween ends is the worst movie
did you watch it song I watched it don't
blow it up
shout out shout out to the homie Jimmy
champagne
I saw his spoiler-free uh uh review and
then his spoiler review
I I love his optimism
but I can't it is I can't
it is literally I feel sorry for Michael
Myers
I feel sorry I don't care about Michael
Myers he got a bag to do that I feel
sorry for me
I'm sitting here watching so you gotta
get better it gotta get better that's
the credit spawned up I'm like it ain't
get better that that is my favorite
Boogeyman and they did him dirty
what's up literally it was the worst
like the first skill is the best
oh okay yeah like okay wow okay so so
just think about the worst possible way
they could have ended that movie and
it's not that it's worse I gotta hit
time with my lords because
super chance please yeah hold on a
second
um
Necromancer sale I might have read this
but uh remember for 12 months here's
another great show Lords and thanks for
the pillow thank you sir I appreciate it
I know what you're saying
y'all said it real fast
it's crazy there we go spark going 17
two pounds Super Chat we rolling into
the CMA HQ with toppy Shelby
they don't focus on the cloud dominance
aspect because that doesn't concern Sony
but God does like I said I said it last
week though that is a dumb argument the
Cod argument is a dumb argument and I I
tend to agree with cops everything is a
Doug argument yeah I tend to agree that
it's just you trying to get as many
concessions as possible when it comes to
that game but beyond that
oh sorry I think it's just a matter of
perspective for us the consumers is a
dumb argument but for Jim dance move
Reigns over there trying to get this
deal
strongest hand right now yeah this is
what he doing
is it like is cod really the strongest
hand
I saw a building I saw a YouTube video
that said that they make more money off
of Call of Duty every year that money
that's all of their exclusives combined
I heard that I think we that's why I
said if the dirt comes out and this goes
we are gonna see because Microsoft will
be first to pull up the books or how
much they really benefited for that
being whatever it gonna get dirty yeah
what's up
all of this like all the Call of Duty
Revenue
is more than the exclusives right
guess what how does that how does that
positively affect the consumer not at
all okay
this is how you fold them in one
when this deal go through you have made
so much bad calm around you guys you
should have just shut up you should have
just took the deal but once we know once
this is removed that you don't have any
triple lays that can fill that bank back
up
gonna starve you out we're gonna wait
you out I don't even they got enough
money to take the loss so they don't
need your money they don't need it and
they're gonna starve you out
I think their biggest concern good is
not in the in the near future I think
they're like look after a couple years
of call of being in Game Pass every year
how much more of the market are we going
to start losing I honestly think that's
a legit concern or closure I think
that's the strong like because I tell
people long term I will give gymnasts
and I said this on defining Duke the
argument I think he has is that
Microsoft could say yeah we extend it
for whatever 2027 or whatever right but
it's going to be in Game Pass every one
of those years and then the next console
generation let's just say there's a bad
situation on The Re-Up King
but let's just say
let's go in another Direction yeah
exactly that
they could do so many things they could
be like yeah you know um so all the Call
of Duty games that are going to other
platforms are going to be term-based
strategy games yeah and the shooters are
gonna stay out there and if you want
that real what's that that main vein you
want that organic hey you gotta come
over together
like King you always said it the lights
could be turned off switch the lights
off and In fairness they want
concessions on that I think I don't
agree is yo all the you know that's I
don't agree but the things I think
they're big extra with the features
there's that when clearly if you look at
the red tape that you see all the Call
of Duty exclusive stuff that's coming
out right now it just doesn't look it
looks bad for the Optics as far as what
PlayStation has done in the past with
this franchise and how they've moved
comparison to what they're demanding
Xbox two is kind of funny to me okay
I think that you know most likely Jim's
trying to put a lot of pressure on
social media a lot of pressure in the
media a lot of pressure the uh you know
to see it's whatever their initials are
so that Microsoft eventually sends sends
that okay let's talk well what's it
gonna say and then if he's doing his
arming his dimwits him what's out here
to think uh Sony's actually making sense
and they're fighting for it yeah we want
to pay more we like being dominated it's
like we probably do need to move on yeah
exactly yeah
I think hold on a second we got free R
Kelly five dollars in the chat Kang [ __ ]
yourself cave they got no backbone Sony
owns Microsoft leases
it's such a shame that you're a part of
that group Chelsea but
seeing where you currently are and
you're residing it does kind of make
sense
lights out
the thing is is they they got this much
money on the line they have to make they
have to to stand like they have to move
in a room full of snakes
all the way through the door
and we gotta throw the taco five dollars
Super Chat we got to throw in the topic
talking about the head of obsidian
saying that they'll be knocking at
Fallout their next projects if they can
check out the Virgo shout out to the
Black Rock yes
that's interesting new news I actually
made a video about that yeah saying that
they should do that not the music badly
plays and Jazz they started moving I
think it's gonna happen from shitty this
year because I'll be honest I think that
was the last hope because Bethesda don't
look like they're interested with
Starfield and then Elder Scrolls
afterwards it's not that they're not
interested I don't think they have the
time the time yeah correct I I honestly
feel like what I keep saying is going to
happen there's going to be a cold
development yeah between Bethesda and
obsidian where both studios are making
follow-ups yes and shout out to Maddie
they think even making like so he called
it Vault Studios you get the heads and
because there's no way there's too much
money for everybody to lose out with no
Fallout degeneration anyway moving on
yeah yeah no we got heck to the Macho
Man five dollar super chat if my next
girlfriend isn't as loyal as Chris Hart
it's the PlayStation I don't wanna whoa
in fact then we have the king of
tic-tock toe play show up on YouTube
pull up you can't hear it oh that's
that's unfortunate
but over here though
that's like this he's a gangster yeah
that's it we're caught up I know Dallas
cows yeah okay I got kills I really kill
them
Bill said we bike we buy Cod it ain't
coming to Sony gym and Jim said haha
yeah you're not doing that yeah I mean I
don't know Jim was literally on saying
uh Phil said he's gonna take our our toy
away after three years so you know hey
okay but we appreciate your ramen
noodles there's nothing I can say he's
so delusional I don't know
we do appreciate hello Miss God bless we
do appreciate your five dollar uh you
know I know you usually spend that on
Ramen at the conversation
you outside you know what I'm saying No
Doubt let's get into it it's the hot
white attic it's your topic will be set
it up when you're good
um
you know what uh awesome go ahead you
said it out so uh the character that
plays Bayonetta uh she came out on
Twitter yesterday this actually pretty
much right off the press uh the end of
the person who is well we'll get to that
in a second so she came out and pretty
much said that
she was only offered 4 000 USD and
that's important because clearly we're
not the only currency in the world uh
they only offered four thousand dollars
for the role of bayonet and keep in mind
I don't I've never played a Bayonetta I
don't particularly like those like
Corridor games where you like kill
people yeah you move to another section
these magical walls pop up kill more
people you move to another section
me see but I feel like God of War hasn't
been without Authority right yeah
it matters though that's why I don't not
like I like Devil May Cry for the Lord I
don't like it for this uh for for the
gameplay it's just how it is and yeah
they offer her four thousand dollars to
voice act an entire game and I don't
know I don't know how much dialogue's in
bayonet is there a lot of dogs it's
another I mean her voice is Iconic and
what I mean by that is like I'm not
saying that it's the greatest voice ever
whatever but
when you hear Bayonetta speak he knows
Bayonetta right yeah so uh yeah that
that yeah I don't know the details but
this doesn't it doesn't sound good this
doesn't none of this seems good but
that's a whole context because before it
came out um
Platinum have made us an issue statement
staying that um that that various
overlapping circumstances made it
difficult for Helena Taylor that's who's
boycotta to reprise her role we held
auditions to cast a new voice of
Bayonetta and offered the uh roll to
Jennifer Hale whom we felt was a good
match for the character I understand the
concern and this is to your point addict
now she's disputing this um hello saying
that that's that's not the case
I will say one thing we don't know at
both sides that is correct for the most
part we just know hers uh she is coming
out very vocally like most people don't
come out this open and this vocal unless
they feel like they got they got proof
they got everything and she's I mean
she's breaking and breaking NBA yeah
that's how strongly she feels about this
yeah so yeah good I'm sorry I guess for
the most part you know I'm going to
always this is like if she is telling
the truth 100 and her side of the store
and she's not leaving nothing out that
would make her look bad in this
especially time consent like I she said
that she had she there was no time
consent she had nothing but time so
she's 100 in this man I I'm gonna have
to jump on it man first off it's easy to
boy Kyle said I'm gonna go play yeah
yeah
I think I'm a boycott the game I ain't
gonna buy but I do it like look
there's been issues with voice acting
for years in the gaming industry yeah
and I'm 100 if first off I don't think
it was entirely Platinum I do think that
Nintendo had something to do with it too
uh Platinum probably made the final
decision to not give her more money but
Nintendo probably did uh the Nintendo
probably short shot of them as much as
money would take to make a banana so
maybe they didn't fully fund it that's
just speculation going on there but it's
just like
if they are truly doing this someone's
playing the music in the background yeah
I hear I hear us in the background I
don't know but if they are truly trying
to give this woman four thousand dollars
to play Bayonetta boycott the game I'm
sorry well yeah at this point like you
know it's one thing to boycott something
for the consumers it's another thing we
got a boycott something for the people
that actually make the art that we play
like yeah like y'all go like the pro
continues so real quick so in her own
statement she says this as well she says
the final offer to do the whole game as
a buyout as a buyout flat rate was 4 000
USD so again I don't what I glean from
that language is that this was they they
already wanted this to be her last game
whether they're going to continue
bayonet or not it seemed like they were
going to move another different
direction and they wanted this to be her
last game anyway right so that kind of
indicates it's an indicator to me that
it was like well you purposely sort of
disrespect her to force her to leave
right yeah right because again I don't
know what she meant by this in this
language but me reading it feels like
hey they told her this is going to be
the last game or this is going to be the
last game with you in it here's the what
we're gonna pay you maybe that was
issues in Bayonetta too you know maybe
there's conflicting interests I don't
know if I'm understanding for the very
beginning and people in the class they
say she didn't take the job stuff said
look I wouldn't take the job either but
it would be four thousand dollars to do
a roll first off she this woman went out
there she she dude she got some man she
went out there and said yeah it made
this much money she wasn't supposed to
say that like that she she definitely
broke broke I said made like what 450
million dollars for both of them for
everything
so it's just like they clearly had the
bread it's like I said
um a lot of that is people uh people
don't understand the way this generally
Works a publisher most the time funds
the entire game unless there's a
Kickstarter going on but most of the
time it is a publisher funding the game
that's why I'm saying you know that
money isn't relevant to the matter
because
the publisher paid but uh well you know
there's a lot of stuff going to the the
actual developer usually coach Sean's
these they try to get the game funded
then they get the game funded I maybe
maybe Platinum didn't ask for enough
money to actually fund the game properly
and they're trying to cut certain things
in the game to be able to properly fund
the game and maybe her her actual
um you know what she would normally make
was part of it but it's just like but
the thing is then you hire Jennifer Hale
you didn't hire just anybody you ain't
hire Calvin
and now let's get to the other side
which is it's a bit very controversial
because
she basically let me let me quote it
because I won't miss quote it because
this is the part that people are some
people are distanced their self from her
side and they said um Taylor then spoke
about him replacing her saying that she
wishes her all the best but she has no
right to say she is Bayonetta they now
have a new girl versus her over and I
love actors and I wish her all the joy
in the world and all the jobs but she
has no right she has no right to sign
merchandisers Bayonetta any more than I
have the right to sign is Eva Green even
though I was her parent in Golden
Compass that portrayal is hers and hers
alone and then he said she said they'll
probably try to do a spin-off with Gene
but don't buy that either so she's kind
of upset that Jennifer Hale took the job
you know and yeah to look you could sit
there and say don't boycott something
because you didn't get a paycheck but to
say don't boycott something with another
actor going forward actions going
forward that's I do feel like that might
be a little bit
there's too much ownership that she's
trying to sort of exude over the over
the the actor over the the the character
I mean at the end of the day Bayonetta
one of the biggest appeals to people is
that that voice yeah so she does got a
little bit of points like could you have
done this without me
nah but at the same point but this is
the thing right
end of the day she made a decision not
to take it right
no no I get it but what did you expect
to happen them shutting down the game
can I say one last thing she tried to
call their blog
we don't know for sure that the save bag
was offered what if Jennifer Hale
because of us I mean what what happens
if this wasn't about almost guaranteed
she got a bigger bag right because what
about if this wasn't about the money it
was about getting her out of the problem
right what if this was a slow okay I
know you ready you've been patient it's
just the fact that okay everything that
indicates from from looking at it right
you you don't offer the same budget that
you gave for the first time and the
second time you don't offer those two
budgets they don't get your residuals
okay but you but you came you didn't
offer her the same salary because she
wasn't screaming the first time right
wasn't screaming a second time but the
third time it comes up right now now you
low baller
so that means that her salary before was
greater than
right because she would have said
something before I don't
right I don't I don't obviously I really
don't think her salary before was four
thousand dollars right right so you we
have to assume from what's laid in front
of us because she wouldn't have made a
stink if this was the same salary that
she was getting for the other two games
she wouldn't make it a stink here
because it would have been common to be
fair though wouldn't you assume if the
game's getting more attraction more
popularity it's getting more money
getting more budget you would expect
your like you can't ex like good example
Iron Man Johnny Depp Robbie Downey Jr do
you think he made the same amount he
made an Iron Man that he made an Iron
Man three no I think that probably
doubled for the differences and remember
the original Bayonetta was across all
platforms whereas two two and three are
exclusive to Nintendo right they gave
him
a set amount and it went that way right
he is the face he's the face she's the
voice not the face yeah you got a point
there that's right she's the voice not
the face you can easily uh change out a
a a voice for people they like when they
they change snake remember they changed
no they didn't they they see people
people were tied to like Ironside and
stuff like that when it comes to their
like you know let's say fisher Master
Chief or whoever let's say they remove
back to Chief and that what's what's my
man that Downs yeah it's so I think we
need to start getting back this right
actors and actresses on the show which
is actually break down yeah we
definitely got to do that but the
problem is
this offer is not adequate
this is a non-addequate situation
legit yeah right so you know when she's
telling you that financially she's
looking at ruin here what are you going
to sue her for the clothes on the back
because she doesn't have enough money to
put gas in a car and
um
yeah she said that she said I quote no
keg is right she said hold on let me get
the let me get the boss she was like um
understand it's a thing and she was like
as far as the um okay Fat Cats cream off
the top and leave us the rotten crumbs
and then she goes I quote I'm not afraid
of the non-disclosure agreement I can't
afford to run a car what are they gonna
do take my clothes good luck to them
Bayonetta always stands up for them with
less power and stands up for what's
right and in doing this you stand with
her she's I don't know man I'm sure that
NDA is going to be enforced by Nintendo
at the end of the day she's the little
woman fighting yeah okay you don't own
the character yep right so they get to
do with the character what they want big
but they brought her into a free cast
and she won the spot again right you won
the spot but then you got low ball so
that means all the people they called in
they tried to get rid of her they're all
the people they called in she won the
spot again boom uh
now you send the low ball off I would
like to see the comparison offer to the
person that has the role now but this is
where the salt comes in and I think this
is where she just should have just not
dipped into this toe
she don't the other girl don't have the
right for this yeah
that didn't sound good and I would have
just cut a mic off right before yeah
everything was good right she's good
yeah and okay so I say support All
actors all right sometimes it's kind of
you're not gonna like you say support is
gonna happen yeah right if you get fired
from your job and the next guy comes in
and he's making a little bit more a
little bit less or whatever you're not
gonna like the person taking over
something that you felt that you created
can someone uh let me look up right now
I'm gonna look up what the average
salary is for these boys
and just for clarity there's there is a
union already evolved that yeah all of
them are part of it you they have it for
my understanding you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah she's she's it's it's
gonna work itself out but this the scary
part about it is
when he send the letter back and he said
oh it was some of the greatest times
meeting you and you were right for the
character you were this and you were
that
and then you send back the low ball
offer all right so and she felt that was
disingenuous she thought it was uh
disrespectful and I understand it and I
I know that you know the the basic
budget of the game she thought that she
was gonna get a little bit more I don't
know what happened from point A to point
B yeah but she put the business out
there and is up to these dudes to uh
either rebuff it right or or
um show some financials yeah
here's what it says on you on Google I
can only Google it experience video game
actresses slash actresses will receive
200 to 350 an hour or 50 to 200 per 100
words for their video game acting novice
voice actor they get between one dollar
to five dollars per 100 word so she's
clearly a vet and she made 200 to uh she
was supposed to make 200 to 350 an hour
according to Google so I mean it's gonna
take your about four thousand dollars
easily yeah it's a recording voice to me
it felt like they wanted her out not
necessary right and In fairness because
again the only thing I won't say is we
don't know the full story
I just want to present this scenario I'm
not saying this is true what if she was
difficult to work with that's possible
what is I mean people but like Wesley
Snipes with blade they didn't like
working either he got his butt this was
like you know I like that you know the
people try to soft fire you like soft
kind of games yeah this is then this is
why this is why I'm not for being for
handling people with baby gloves and
diplomacy all the time if you had been
straight up with her and told her look
we don't want you on this anymore this
is what we're willing to give you take
it or leave it right then it would have
been clear and you signed the NDA and
you don't and then you you complain
about it online or you don't but it was
made clear to you that we no longer want
you on this project and that's it
if they try to treat her with baby
gloves it'd be like yeah oh we we love
the fact that you know what you the work
you've done and this that and the other
and then you blow baller and don't tell
her why you low ball her right this is
what happens because the statement they
made was due to various overlapping
circumstances that's what Platinum said
that that made it difficult yeah she did
not she's saying that's BS she said
that's not what happened this is gonna
come out now the question I got for
y'all is y'all know how Nintendo play
these legal streams
that's what I'm saying I'm sorry I I get
that she says they but Nintendo
literally taking people to court taking
everything they made off the money say
you can invest every penny you make for
the next 15 years my question to y'all
do you think Nintendo Platinum make a
statement on a comeback on this one I
don't think Nintendo takes her because
right now it would be very bad on
Nintendo right now I feel like Platinum
is getting the majority of the work for
them but if Nintendo steps in uh look
look I'ma say this okay there's certain
streets on Twitter you don't come across
and she has got those streets very wild
up right now and the last thing you want
is it's like Nintendo is like they're
behind okay you know Platinum they're
like pushing Platinum more and more okay
you taking the moment Nintendo comes out
there and say because at that point when
she's getting sued she she's definitely
going to go out there on Twitter and say
it then all the spotlight gonna come
straight off of who what's what's his
name to Nemo or Kamia
straight from coming into Nintendo and I
don't think Nintendo wants that they'll
probably let her run wild with these now
but here's the thing and as a result of
that if she's in that spotlight
can she theoretically get another job
because other companies may say well
look you know can we you know what I
mean like when you go public and you and
once it's a courageous aspect because
it's one aspect that yo you willing to
fight and die on this right then it's
the other aspect but because you're
willing to do that companies may say yo
she may be arrested I don't know if we
want that heat right now of hiring a
person like this because she may put our
business out so there's two sides to it
and I'm just curious where y'all stand
with with that aspect being really black
bold herself to be honest with you yeah
that's probably a good reason uh you
know me then you know people in the chat
that make a good point Nintendo usually
don't care who they offend they go after
anyone that they they feel offended by
uh her break in NDA to this degree is
probably different than people stealing
Nintendo's property yeah you know maybe
if anything this might get her a check
on the outside just to have her shut up
on on social medias uh but you know
King's right you know uh she probably
blacked out herself blackballed herself
with certain people is the other aspect
her video got more views than the actual
trailer
people want to know what's going on we
love Bayonetta right that's that's no
lie and the fact that the little person
is uh in a position of uh being crushed
by the wheel right we we don't see that
we we always think that we always hope
that these uh companies treat uh the
small guy and we know the small guy is
the voice actor right really when you're
going there small guy is the voice actor
to go in there and give life to the
character and we fall in love with that
life of the character right now that we
hear that this is happening and the deal
with the most shocking part was the four
thousand dollars I think that was the
most shocking part and then she has to
say US dollars
or something
most the time in most of the places the
world our money is going to be more
there anyway but it's just like it's
just crazy
that they offered a four thousand that's
why I kind of think this is like look
you know if you coming over here working
on Bay data and maybe she is hard to
work with in their mindsets like him we
have to work with you again you coming
over here for dirt cheap labor or you
could go find somewhere else to work and
that's why I agree with soft if that was
your issue and maybe she wasn't easy to
work with you should have just said that
so she would have walked away now the
last question we will move on the big
thing is she's telling the community
boycott this game
boycott Bayonetta three and I'm seeing
mix was you know thing I'm seeing people
say yo we riding you don't know
ain't nothing to play on Nintendo you
think they're going boycott
don't do that don't do that
so the thing is so people like yo we
gotta take a stitch like yo like the
talent for the games that we love we we
got we got a ride and then other people
will be like I'll say yo y'all gonna
love the pole
um yo like um she's one person why are
we gonna penalize the rest of the studio
where did the Lord stand let's start
with you attic I think you made yourself
I I think
if she is Justified and she has a
hundred percent received proving stuff
she don't have to say it but as long as
we know what's going on is genuine as
long as she's genuine in the stuff she's
saying boy caught the game but if
there's stuff that she's not telling us
that she refused to work certain days or
she refused to do this or you know she
made them do certain of her voice acting
over the phone or over the Internet uh
you know besides the pandemic uh reasons
then it's just like okay then you know
buy the game because it's on her it's
not on them right I don't know like I
feel like
it's easy to go off one statement
someone says on Twitter
um apparently people in the chat said he
said that she's lying about certain yeah
before he got blocked he threw a
subliminal like we got blocked yeah
before he got locked up out of there
yeah I interviewed you why did you block
me Fam I never even added you I didn't
notice I was black I can't be what's up
I was dead
what the hell anyway it's a gray area
yes
yes I would tweeted the man once I was
like yo I've never I've never even
talked to him
it's just like at this point it's a gray
area it's a very it's a very hard area
to run around because it's like do we
believe this individual Everything 100
she said or do we sit in the middle area
and then there's that one thing like do
we punish a studio for the actions of
one person right that's the question
right it's a hard thing but at the same
time
are we ever going to get to a better
situation with voice actors if we don't
stand with them
bars solve the boycott movement what's
your thoughts on it
she's very adamant but the thing about
it is it's like I would have felt better
about it if she came out and she said
her piece about her situation and then
she had you know she had understanding
and and issues with other parts of the
development process that maybe they were
you know people in lower positions not
getting there just do and maybe it would
have come off better if she had
mentioned that stuff as well because
just saying this and boycott the entire
game because they lowballed me
I agree that if they that was the case
and everything is true about that
situation she had every right not to
take it she should not have taken that
deal and she was well within her rights
not to say that because of this
Injustice done to me
the whole project has to suffer for it
without her pointing to other issues
that might have happened during the
development process with obviously QA
people probably are getting treated well
especially coming out of Nintendo we've
heard about how QA people in Nintendo
you know and and and uh what do you call
it and contract workers at Nintendo like
they don't have access to certain
buildings they don't have let me say
something real quick Saul
I I find it
I find it interesting that she didn't
like attack the situation of okay if you
got paid that you should have done that
she attacked her doing the role in
general that's not your role that's my
role yeah it seemed it seemed like a
bitter it seemed very salty it was it
was it was very salty so to me
should it is it something that we should
be discussed everything is going on
right now that is trending and
everybody's talking about it and there's
discourse around it and it should be
addressed yes should the whole game
suffer for it nah
um
what about
let's just say everything like
everything she said is true and what if
voice actors just say theoretically have
never been able to get a bigger bag and
this is a this is like a industry
plaguing issue and if what about that it
clearly is though okay but this is the
thing but this is the thing right if her
speaking had impulsed God knows how many
voice actors coming out and saying hey
yeah well this this is what happens and
all these people backing Iraq right this
is the problem that I see I don't like I
don't like the industry and by the
industry I mean people like us or or the
or um what you may call it the Press
soap boxing issues that the people that
are affected by them aren't arguing
you know when we could go back talking
about games
but so you replied I got you just to
push back a little bit
all right now if you look at other
people that are trying to make it in
this industry they're scared to say
anything because they don't want to get
blacklisted right Nintendo's a big
company they make multiple games a year
I hear you do you think it's that's what
I'm saying this is not like a simple
this is a gray area it's a super gray
area I think a lot of the reasons that
you see a lot of these other people not
saying nothing because they look look
this is true 100 she's saying it's true
but is it worth me publicly speaking
about the smoke so I get in the same
situation she's in there is there is
power and numbers and the only way it's
really going to change is if the people
who it affects make the change I don't
care how I don't care how many times
Jason Shore comes out and complains
about something that he somebody's told
him it it does not have the same effect
as somebody who it happened to coming
out and standing on the soapbox and
saying this is me this is my name this
is what I've done and this is what's
happened to me I'm sorry I'm not about
that I can't be about that this is what
she should do then
she should have that mentality of like
when people go on strike it's like you
can't shut us all up and get as many as
their friends and get their friends and
their friends to all come together yo I
gotta keep my lights on I got a car too
that I'm trying to keep on I'm trying I
can't get out there dude my strikes are
hard to do in general it's hard to
convince people to not look at their own
self-worth over the self-worth that
right it could be because we don't know
if that could even fix anything right
and this is the thing like she's already
part of a union right right apparently
has made no comment on this not that I
know of that they made a comment on this
right so the thing about it is
because she only focused on her
situation and because of the saltiness
at the end of it where it really feels
like she just has she feels like she has
ownership over this and nobody else
should have it
the the whole idea of boycotting the
game because of just her without any
other context that she could have
brought in it feels selfish and again I
feel for her and I think she did the
right thing for her
but at the end of the day when it comes
to the game being affected
I don't think I don't think they go
together I really don't I really don't
know it's like I said I don't really
have an opinion on the matter it's just
such a great area right right yeah yeah
but okay but the thing you brought up
Coggin is really it I feel strongly
about it because I've seen it we've
we've been seeing it right with these
big these these political issues that
seep into the gaming space right where
it's like a journalist will talk about
it an outlet we'll talk about it and all
of a sudden the outlet all the outlets
have opinions on it right
but the people that it's affecting stays
super quiet and it's like if if it's so
affecting so many people
I mean look what happened what could
happen with with Activision Blizzard
like if people come out and say hey this
is objectively bad
the industry has no option but to listen
because it's going it's going to come
back in on itself so find someone called
not to hug you don't like that I love
myself
very in tune with the conversation I'm
comfortable but um
that's crazy
that's dirty that's dirty but oh look
look at the description go hit that at
the top but all I was going to say is I
do see your point though in reference to
you know I don't want to call it moral
grandstanding but
where if no it's not by the game
then they are automatically vilified
that they should have boycott and that
they have no I don't agree with that I
am seeing that right in that part no you
see here we go that's the part I think
solves argument is very strong I feel
yeah it's not even that I feel like if
you if people want to buy the game it's
it's not their business to maintain her
business relationships all that anger
and frustration should be aimed towards
Nintendo should be aimed towards uh
Platinum because they did it or the ones
that agreed to say to sign her on the
the amount that she had don't don't
blame the consumer for consuming I'm
sorry hold on I'm Max I'm gonna I'm
gonna put you on blast just because I I
mean I hope what you say is true so he
says he's in the CWA this is correct two
low-level employees are scared to strike
we went on strike a few years ago for
four days we got bigger crumbs than the
first officer fourth officer so I mean
we'll see I mean I don't know that
industry and shout out to I believe
Alexander you know we're going to reach
out made a good point we're going to
reach out to voice actors you know and
try to get some more someone put some
what's up so uh put in the chat you know
uh put in the chat who who you guys as
voice acting would like to come back we
probably reach out to her as well and
some others I want to shout out my man
fawns he's you know um he has voice
actors so I believe he had the voice
actor goes to sushima um we need to talk
to bitcloud too yeah we'll see what we
can do it get these emails yeah this is
this is a subject we don't know a lot
about and I want to be clear but to your
point
um addict um and I'll give it to you
King it's just that I I want to be
careful until more information comes out
I don't want to take everything as
verbatim but anyway can you go unless
you and end it up
oh damn King not the fraud alert we're
about to get canceled
I gotta call fraud on myself oh
um okay when I get counselor
was I was boycotting the game uh before
this even happened
because
you know I thought oh she was yeah she
was she was less revealing in uh
character design and the new character
design that was you know strictly
Nintendo and I thought Nintendo made a
couple of calls that you know covered up
uh assets yes assets were definitely so
not revealed now I can't sit here and
act like you know hey man just because
one person stepped up and oh
not the stitching cake
you know um I can't sit there and say
I I this is my reason uh-huh that's not
my reason my reason is purely my reasons
and my reasons only for the reasons why
I was not purchasing said game until
they give a different uh characters
skins
um but uh this part right here yeah
she said legally yeah they were in line
with doing what they would justify for
doing whatever they did legally I want
you to hear that part they made an offer
to her legally and she declined
that's the end of the the relationship
right they give you an offer you decline
said offer no harm no foul you felt that
they owed you something because you were
a staple or you helped build up
something just because you helped build
up something don't give you ownership
upset thing they own IP their own
likeness they own everything they even
own the ability to change the voice if
they're not comfortable with you
um I don't think this is the battle that
you can win and on that Hill other
people are not going to look up at you
and say that you can win this battle
because at the same time you have said
to boycott the game from another voice
actor getting the job that accepted
whatever offer they gave right so what
was inadequate to you was adequate to
someone else but we don't know what they
got though we don't know that but what
we do know is she took the job right yes
yes and they gave her what they felt
that she was worth yes so again
this is one person's issue
um I don't want to sound uh heartless in
this but they gave you a contract you
declined the contract now you made the
situation public right okay so you deal
with it from that point but to have
people rally behind you to say a game
that they were waiting for for so long
uh boycott the game because you felt
that the offer that they offered you was
inadequate right I think that's a little
bit stretching and people are going to
eat the side with you or they're not
right and um I hope that you get a lot
of people to Rally behind you I like a
sovereign set I would rather
the people in your industry that this is
affecting for you to Galvanize that
group and for that group to go forth and
fight with you your peers your people
but you're asking people that are not
your peers that are just consumers to
step away from something that they're
very passionate about
um I I don't think you're gonna win that
battle but get your the people that
you're uh you're working with those
people that are inside those rooms
sometimes I know you can do it remotely
now but get your groups get your
illustrious team together and go and
fight on that hill and fight for more uh
economic uh fairness when it comes to
that no doubt I'm gonna fall just read
our final statement just to make sure
we're clear with what she said she said
um and what did they think this was
worth that mean Platinum Nintendo
whatever what did they offer to pay me
the final offer to do the whole game as
a buyout flat rate was 4 000 US Dollars
this is an insult to me the amount of
time I took to to work on my talent and
everything that I have given to this
game to the fans I'm asking the fans to
boycott this game and instead spend that
money that you would have spent on this
game donating to charity I don't want
the world I didn't ask for too much I
was just asking for a decent dignified
living way it's kind of crazy she didn't
act she didn't like vocalize what she
asked for either she said what they did
was legal but it was immoral yeah that's
what she's standing on so we would try
to get more context I think okay what
makes this such a big story is it's the
it's a character like Bayonetta yes but
the main characters character like this
is huge yeah for instance if like let's
say Spider-Man and like MJ's one day she
didn't get what she wanted and she left
any character for that matter and they
weren't the main character I feel like
it would be a different conversation but
because the main character wanted more I
don't know how much money that because
she didn't say that's what makes this
interesting is they said to the main
character of banana Bayonetta go kick
rocks we good yeah we gotta see we wait
for more information to come out we will
try the Lord's like at example we try to
get Borah voice actor Talent on the
program try to get more of this
information to get don't know if it'll
be on iO people or at least yeah we'll
at least try to figure out that's what I
got soft you got super chat sir yep hold
on one sec so we got let me see I'm
Gonna Roll back a little bit
uh and then we have the Andrew 13 to our
Super Chat most shocking part is that a
Nintendo game has voice over oh that has
voice actors that's crazy that's crazy
let's not let's not try to comment too
much on the super chest we don't got a
lot yeah
we'll come by the last two topics yeah
spawn go 175 pound Super Chat and deck
economy I tried saying she was lying
with no receipts you got a lion
annihilated in the quote tweets and
started blocking people with legitimate
questions yeah it wasn't a nice scene
that's for sure then we got THX 1138 two
dollars Super Chat Kojima did that same
did the same with uh snake voice actor
and metal gear solid five yes we know
what we're not talking about is why they
didn't want her back it wouldn't be for
no reason especially since Jennifer Hale
will always cost more
um that's the thing I don't think
Jennifer Hill costs four thousand
dollars I wouldn't Jennifer Haley's yeah
that's a good point
Harkey to me ten dollar Super Chat is 4
000 out of the Norms do voice actors
really make that much why should a voice
actor make more than the many people
that actually made the game she ended
her voice acting career with this move
it was it was debatable she was
debatable you could have done that but
as we said the four thousand dollars for
an actor with her experience is sort of
out of pocket that's not doesn't sound
good uh Cadron Hardy oh hey Fozzy what's
up
I think she knows her and she took the
job knowing what the deal was she's
talking about Jennifer Hale I guess
then we got David Crossing member for
six months Lord Bronx not to mention
she's part of a union and taking a
lowball offer like that might impact
what other owners of voice actors get
for their other projects that's another
thing again I don't know 100 or 4 000
because I know she wouldn't take it yeah
that makes sense don't the taco ten
dollars which is the only console that
went the entire year without going two
months without a big exclusive stop the
cap addict even without made of the
three there's Mario plus rabbits too
this month you know who's coming forward
Donna talk if you feel that strong about
me playing Nintendo games you know
that's super Chatham I play more
Nintendo games
my screen just blacked out wigged up
okay no I got it I got it okay add me
and grand five dollar Super Chat first
we got Sam precious voice change then
solid stick and now Bayonetta what the f
then we got Spartan go 17 two about two
pounds which at Revolution is easy when
your bread ain't on the line
there we go
there we have it Jaffe likes big white
women
I don't know
that might be him what's up just the one
dollar Super Chat appreciate it yeah
we have a slow boat back slap remember
Hill was the voice of Commander separate
in Mass Effect Trilogy and best
dealership in Kotor she ain't taking 4K
to be Bayonetta have we ever thought
that maybe this is a Jennifer hell move
and not her like she actually had
friends there that got her that role and
they had to push her up because of it
but once again why not be honest about
it and you just love it it's gonna be so
hard to say yo she got friends we don't
want you we want her that's a hard time
I'm sorry if I'm in charge of something
I'm I I haven't I'm handling your baby
gloves
so what benefit does it do to me
I think what it is those songs
I think one of this song was we live in
such a sensitive world having a
conversation like that might get you
canceled I don't live in that sensitive
World
you'll be honest with me all right
that's it we're caught up all right cool
let's get to it the next topic we'll do
a little combo King as far as the um
Xbox the Keystone I'm gonna be out here
in 15 minutes yeah this is this all
right
don't be doing it that was funny though
so look um King I set it up uh Keystone
looks like Phil Dominus might have died
you know
Yoda Laurie said
yeah you give me you can't give me gives
me warm moments I can't shout out to uh
Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive you know what I'm saying had
the uh the shelf of all shelves back in
the in the mix again on Twitter and uh
the question is did Xbox tease the
Keystone the rumored cloud gaming
console so looks like yeah again on that
show looks like a very smaller device
you know what I'm saying this could be
the one shout out to chess Gordon with
no Central it was one of the uh first
people to report on the existence of
this device and it would be a streaming
console kind of all just much smaller
than this it looks like a series that's
but smaller so that was uh one of the
first news and then the second news I'll
I'll jump in for me obviously
quote-unquote home team on meta and uh
what you call it uh Sacha Nadella and
Microsoft uh came out made a statement
in reference to the actual um
partnership and having um a lot of
Microsoft products as far as teams
things like that and that nature and
Office 365 coming to VR are but one of
the other bigger aspects of the deal was
on Xbox cloud gaming and that coming to
the the quest device as well so let's
start with King's part first king
Keystone where you at with this man
oh we I love it so when you send uh the
two uh pincer attacks in the big console
and then you send little man little man
is doing so much disruptive stuff in the
in the marketplace
then we have the troops
that the pawns the little pieces on the
boards the you know hey for all your TCO
guys
this is for you hey Chris I saw you
tagged me in a on a picture and I think
that was more appropriate for yourself
but again yeah this this works for you
you got that what is it what was it
called it was a fat boy special right so
is it a fat boy
that's exactly what it said it said Fat
Boys wow on on the caption everybody
gotta go put it up all right so and I
find it really weird but I guess it's
because it's an hour with the popcorn
um
Microsoft can actually get a console out
because it's a streaming console no SSD
none of that stuff involved none of that
stuff
with a controller for buck 59.
Game Pass
now this is for those people that don't
have one of those televisions like a
Samsung so ultimately TCL dudes
that has the app on it for Game Pass
right
and now you have this sort of dedicated
device that is just built around
streaming and giving you the best
possible stream that you can get
for such a low entry price
this is the disruption in the market
that is necessary this is for those
individuals that are sitting on the
fence this is for an economy that is
probably bottoming out right now with
higher taxes with higher uh grocery
prices where entertainment really is few
and far between and you're looking for
some form of uh just a fix to get your
gaming on maybe you're not into gaming
on the highest level as far as a series
X go and maybe a series s is not inside
your whale house you got your switch you
got your PlayStation 5 and you you just
want to have that little bit of Xbox
flavor
oh Phil Dominus Maximus a really
expensive though
and on his shelf now I know you guys is
like y'all reaching king I said I was
reaching when they show Kojima that
little Cloud situation in his hand
everything on that shelf beneficial
shelf is undefeated it has been
and I don't believe like other people
say oh that that's the Prototype no
that's the unit
that's the unit the last time he had a
series s on the Shelf oh that was the
Prototype no that was the unit they
don't run around he don't run around
giving you prototypes you're not going
to see a prototype this is the unit so
that little unit looking like a little
series that's a little man's little man
it is
this this thing I want to know how
disruptive you feel that this is going
to be in the market and it's not about I
know ABK is great but could you imagine
Call of Duty on the goal you just grab
your controller and something that you
can throw in your pocket and walk out
the door
this is out of control right now yeah
big big big announcement you know I mean
quote unquote reveal let's get out of
adding stuff away for a minute so let's
get solved what you feel man the uh
rumored
Keystone or attic back eating I'll I'll
just say one thing it's streaming I I I
believe in my streaming brothers that
they want something like this they can
have something like this but I'm eating
my sandwich while you got stuff thank
you so so kind if you care about our
Stephen Brothers No Doubt oh shout
itself so what you have man what do you
think about it if this is the uh the
device itself its intended purpose I
think what's interesting is that the
advice is is as big as it is post like
you know what everybody talked about
like a streaming stick or whatever so
you wonder what kind of guts are in this
uh I affectionately call Mini man call
them many men
what's interesting is again I thought
I'm looking at a like a chrome stick
fire stick type of thing and it looks
like it's a lot much larger piece of Kit
so it's like okay what's in there then
um so that's interesting to me because
again we've talked about in the past how
you could sort of Leverage some local
stuff in conjunction with Cloud stuff to
make stuff even run even better or
whatnot so I'm interested to see where
they take this
um
but again it's it is that thing of like
they're making it
as the as the tech continues to improve
as they get more servers across the
world the idea of this being a viable
alternative to local play for some
people is going to increase and uh
that's what they want they they continue
to want that proliferation of Game Pass
and the Xbox ecosystem through Cloud all
over the damn place and they just little
by little they're continuing to do that
um to the point where they're going to
be everywhere they're going to be
everywhere and there really isn't going
to be a
a way that if you really want to access
the Xbox ecosystem that you won't be
able to do it so this is cool we knew it
was coming oh I again I'm surprised by
by the size of the piece of Kit and I'm
interested to see what the guts of it
are so definitely in terms of that
um in terms of the meta and Xbox
partnership
that that that's pretty awesome man I've
been to see all the to get cloud gaming
in in the VR space that's a very cool
thing
um again it's a matter of seeing how it
works
um what would interest me the most is
this new high-end products
yeah fifteen hundred dollar meta Quest
Pro looking good commercial device
I'll come 1500 commercial device
um yeah I didn't even know that we was
attacking that one yeah I didn't know
either
but it looks it looks hot it looks hot
premium very premium um so yeah oh yeah
the medicine Xbox stuff again it goes
back to what I just said
tentacles everywhere tentacles are
everywhere this is what Jim should be
worried about
this is what he's worried about because
this is the thing right when you look at
that right and you look at the fact that
we're going to get a psvr to first
quarter of of next year probably
high-end machine right high-end system
it's going to be still Tethered to the X
to the PS5 right and the power of the
PS5 is going to be powering that machine
it's still going to be a closed
ecosystem right
as you see the success of the meta Quest
2 they're probably there's going to
probably be a successor to that that is
also untethered and and less expensive
in addition to the high-end stuff
what what is psvr to like uh unless psvr
2 comes day one with the games and gives
you a road map of exclusive stuff coming
to them
they have to be very careful because
they have real competition now in the
way that they did it before where before
they were the entry level and if you
want to get into VR you didn't want to
spend a whole lot of money PlayStation
VR was where it's at right now the
market is different now you have
competition you have untethered
competition right and now you're coming
into a market where you know
honestly if you come in higher than four
hundred dollars
you're going to get pushback you're
going to get pushed back so we'll see
we'll see is very interesting times in
the in the VR space
um
thank you well um
that 1500 price point was very revealing
to me to even have it to even say that
it's being done and knowing exactly
what's coming behind it that if you know
the price tag of uh what's said to
become
and you added up all the parts so I
think I probably lowballed the situation
when I said 900 but
um add in the price of the PlayStation
with the 50 upgrade uh that was 550 plus
tax we'll be looking at it close to 600
uh you need a PlayStation five right
this is necessary right so you talk
about the oil and Cummins unit that is
uh uh 1500
so let's say that the PlayStation VR is
like 800 bucks yeah and I know y'all
saying chill right y'all singing chill
though
well okay let's let's say let's say 600
right make it 12. yeah a good even 12 12
on 12 12. right all right so it's let's
say it's a 600
that's not far-fetched and they did they
did the numbers they said our our
premium experience is 14.99 and it's
untethered so 15 is good they and it's
all in one unit we buy you go here you
gotta find a PlayStation five
then you can get the VR but then you got
to get the games and it's not not
untethered
1200 plus tax we're looking at a
fourteen hundred dollar situation
they could have probably looked at the
numbers and this is in line with what
they're going with and they have no fear
because to be this bold to say that you
have to know and you can't have done
this in the vacuum you have to know that
the competition is coming behind you is
going to be close in price
and I really believe that to be the case
as far as Xbox being on meta
holy crap Game Pass inside meta
that means Microsoft has done two things
that everybody's been asking for in a
fail swoop the little cloud gaming
handheld thing there goes your handheld
that y'all been begging for with x Xbox
game pass built inside we want Microsoft
to compete in a VR space
bow
right there without making a hardware
without making it the units are there
for you to pick up you have the little
man with it which is the white unit
with his Oculus too and you have the
series X Type unit is the black unit the
bigger box yo they have literally
they've done you wanted them to compete
without even doing the work yo this is
what happens when your money long boy
you can jump in tag somebody else in to
do the work and you just add your stuff
on to it this is this is the greatest
time to be a gamer
yeah I'll try to jump in real quick so
in reference to the you know the first
thing with um Keystone yeah like this is
kind of like the kind of like most like
secret that most everybody got to do
about already that they're working out
looks like they're engaging interested
just going to he he was gonna Duke and
he said that um he speculates 99 with a
controller
and if anybody hit that price 159
he said 99.
I'm gonna die on this hill so yeah if if
it's 99 I think because to me for it to
make sense being as a streaming console
it's you can't have little man close to
it because little man's three you know
what I'm saying and like I feel like you
got to be a differential because it's
gonna be a a user who let's be honest
they still never a console guy and they
are just like hey you put this and from
my understanding the UI is supposed to
have kind of like similar to what like
uh one of those uh Google kind of
devices where it has like the the
streaming apps you know the Netflix and
all that stuff so if you have a suite of
apps and then the secondary thing with
um with uh Game Pass and stuff bothered
in yeah it could be an entry point for
Regions that like I said are not looking
to commit big big budget to the um to
the Xbox ecosystem and we'll see okay I
go live 100 bucks I'm sitting over here
look at Roku yeah 4K that's what I was
saying 50 60. you could pay 100 bucks
get access to Game Pass but for cloud
service so you can link up to your 5G
Network I don't think people realize and
not to mention that once you perfect
this and you start reaching out to
Comcast yo let's put this service in
your in your I don't think people
realize how big there's a reason Netflix
got the way it was it wasn't their
original haunt it was the fact that they
were offering it to your Xbox to your
Comcast delivery like people don't
realize that that works very well
yeah wait I said the British CMA will
say 99 is too cheap Gamers need to pay
what y'all
like if what if what jazz is saying is
true it ain't able to hit that hundred
dollar sweet spot with a controller with
all the streaming apps with Game Pass
you get that let's say they hit you with
the month to three months you know trial
so they get you in like you get a taste
let you rock out with that huge library
and then what we assume you know like
the Call of Duties and all the first
party exclusives that would be
tremendous right as far as the second
part as far as the partnership um
shout out to myself for making the call
I'm just joking I do know but shout out
to Young Odin as king cause of young all
of the pleasant surprise to see young
older come down there with Zaki and they
start talking they talk you know they
obviously they had the uh office suite
stuff for teams and and all that stuff
the productivity software stuff which I
I thought was interesting but to me I
think that's probably the biggest reason
this this partnership was amazing oh
yeah The Game Pass is probably slid in
yeah because because the vibe I got is
obviously you know the the quest Pro is
it's the commercial device so for
productivity software and all that kind
of stuff you you need the professional
stuff the a plus stuff that people are
usually utilizing this space so that's
one but for me selfishly because I'll be
honest all I care is about the gaming
aspect that's my primary focus it was a
pleasant surprise to see gay past the
ex-cloud streaming integration I think
it's a big deal I think it I think it
serves both purposes I think one from
the from the meta perspective you know
you're going to have p people and what
we call what they call regular game with
pancake Gamers
yeah they're gonna there's gonna be VR
guys that that's just where they are
they're not trying to experience
anything else but VR so you're not going
to get them necessarily to play in a
console space so you're getting an
additional service to have these games
that now you can just try in VR now
granted it's not going to be in VR it's
still going to be like just a big screen
almost projected so we got to see all
the streaming and all that goes but the
fact to have that accessibility to a
base and this is Xbox's portion now to a
base that wouldn't necessarily you know
buy you know a an Xbox console so to
speak now you're giving them a screen an
entry point that's the Xbox Mission it's
like remember Phil's statement we will
go on places where Game Pass exists this
is the Trojan Horse get them in there
right more use it you can say what you
want if you don't believe about you know
I I know I heard that I heard yeah
I didn't even think about that like he
he's literally a man of his word yeah he
passes it so hey hey if if Call of Duty
gets took off PlayStation we got a place
for you it's called Oculus you don't
want to buy an Xbox you can buy Oculus
because he would go hard with the sled
you don't say he's right but look at the
end of the day you can say what you want
about you don't believe in metaverse at
all that's fine you know that he teaches
all but my thing is at the end of the
day that is an entry point in the space
that they are meta is the biggest at as
far as the adoption rate right so we're
just gonna look at the facts and
adoption rate they are the biggest from
the VR perspective right the most
installed base so to speak we know psvr
2 is coming respectfully but right now
this is what it is and like King said an
untethered experience so you're giving
that large base access to Game Pass
right that is a huge deal and it helps
both we'll see long-term him how it
works out when it it comes available is
it going to be you know now in the
future but I think that was a really
cool thing for gamers as far as that
entry point and yeah that's all I mean I
really had to say on that like I said it
was just cool to see young girl didn't
come out there oh when I am old and I
apologize because I put a picture I was
so excited to see you on the screen and
the way I took the picture from my TV
made his head look crazy I apologize
that was not my I was so excited I
didn't realize that they had him looking
crazy so I had to fix that but anyway
that's all I got to say all to anything
else as far as the Keystone and the VR
and we could do that uh nice little wrap
up
a couple of super chats real quick we
got Gerald Mac two dollars which had
Xbox and Microsoft on octopus hustle
type ish
and everywhere and everywhere and we got
black Ronin three five seven ten dollar
Super Chat Comcast guy here they are in
talks internally to see if creating a
potential competitor to Game Pass is
viable or not I see their gaming
division ramping up talks on streaming
games via the X1 platform
and that's it oh cool cool all set so
look another poll that we are going to
rock to get up out of here I'll get a
little short show because I got to get a
plane
um IOP pole with the latest controversy
regarding bayonetta's voice actress
wages and call for a boycott where do
you stand in relation to buying
Bayonetta three you're the only people I
know that can have almost a three-hour
show and say this is a short podcast for
us
chances are a Gamers they need to take a
unified stance against unfair wages
given to underappreciated talent in the
games industry B Gamers should not feel
socially pressured to penalize the
remaining members of the dev team and
still enjoy the game or see I don't care
we need to take a stand against the real
issue plaguing the industry 30 frames
per second in these next Generations
shout out to all the Lords when it goes
up rocking and rolling and again shout
out to the great people of valari please
support the Lords again this is for a
good cause it is a gaming support pillow
my brothers I'm telling y'all right now
I've played it I've used it this is one
of the things you do not realize you
don't need until you until you realize
you need until you actually use it and
it's really I can't actually play my
games without it it's that good again
first 100 pre-orders you get the 15 off
Lord 15 as soon as you go to the link
the link is pinned to the chat and it
will be in the description go support us
if we do this if we hit our Target we
could do bigger things so encourage a
friend tell a friend tell a friend
valari's doing good things we're trying
to do good things this is actually for a
good cause y'all and it's a really
comfortable pillow like No Cap so please
support that the realm Lord attic where
can the five people find you what you
got going on sir
can follow me on Twitter the Lord addict
IOP you can find me on YouTube at gaming
addict I release a video this morning on
scorn so definitely go check that out
pretty sure for coming through we had up
to I think 730 people you know it's a
great show and uh we'll see you next
week done already DJ oh DJ oh it's like
four more out they're not used to this
three they think it is
what you got going on despite coughing
up along I'll be going to work
you know you know how to be yeah
come on in the morning
shout out yeah real quick flame too
lovely chat love y'all see you next week
salute
[Laughter]
[Music]
look we're gonna find people find you
what you got going on sir I'm just
calling out for the realm to just go to
Villari and I'll just go hit up those
pillows trust please I believe it's a
premium situation I got a lot of people
that said my DM that uh you know said
they can you know they show me their
receipts y'all I'll purchase I'm in
um and trust you will definitely love
the quality the build quality of its
innocent Jason Max you gotta relax I
used to gig with a pillow on my lap but
my wife accused me of covering by what
brother
hey hey maybe so now you're doing it in
style now you got more surface area to
protect yeah and
and your wife won't complain it's not
covered
with a peekaboo skirt anyway
um
surprise
catch me on Twitter uh attic and I
should be uh running out that show uh
pretty soon because uh graphic artist
finished up with a couple of projects
that I had in the background I'm working
on and we're just looking for the
overlay and attic and eyes and so we can
talk about stuff like scoring or we can
talk about Hollywood I mean Hollywood uh
Halloween ends I can get his uh topic
and look at this Z look at those garbage
look at that look at them pop up so yeah
so we know that that show is gonna be
definite fire I mean I'm gonna have
something to talk about oh and hopefully
next weekend we can get in uh a little
grounded yeah yeah you guys can uh see
that but I was gonna play yesterday have
a great flight on me and playing scoring
instead please uh everybody wish us uh
Cog well on his flight okay travels
there and back because you know he's
dipping out over there so he has to go
to the CMA and he has to uh
yeah yeah yeah so
have to count the gym we send it in the
Cog the [ __ ] the founder of the Cog
blocker
so [ __ ] is going to go over there
because he's strong enough to handle
I would not be in Brussels but I will be
in Ireland so all my Irish Lloyds info
you gotta go over to Ireland first
because you know we got to get through
before they snitch
okay he's over there first
look again appreciate everybody in there
respect and again we will be back next
week everybody enjoy I see the
membership shout out to Dragonheart Yogi
gifted five eye law podcast of
adversation that is love go hit it up
again go hit up the Volari hopefully we
can do a hot [ __ ] challenge with
everybody here oh God no yeah let's not
do that akw hit me up you already know
if y'all already got covered you trying
to get it as soon as he heals up let's
see
all right cool everybody look enjoy your
weekend peace and we will see you next
week gotta go Kyle gotta go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you